dale shikari enters a graduate school of
arts and sciences a lot of the reason
why I've been successful in my career as
a lawyer is based on what I learned here
in an ironic kind of twist I was a
specialist in Byzantine art and American
Impressionism to vastly different fields
being in the graduate school you're
treated as a scholar you're here
purposefully to look at primary sources
to engage in thoughtful dialogue it's a
skill set it's a disappoint it's a drive
to think out of box that discipline that
I learned in my early days at Columbia
became very instructive for my career as
a criminal lawyer my work with the
Graduate School which I came to almost
somewhat reluctantly after 20 years
became a nice Oasis and became more of
amused I really look forward to coming
back to campus to meeting my board
members one of the goals of our alumni
association has been to create a greater
community particularly within the
umbrella of the
University Alumni Association it's been
a bit like hurting feral cats but but I
think we've made a lot of progress we
just grew with pride as a family seeing
every dot ago here thrive love the
University they're all part of the
University fabric as alumni and I could
not be more delighted walking on a roll
library I felt like a rock star it's
very easy for me to wear a gsas mantle a
very proudly because that is the
strength and that is the rock on which I
think my legal career has been built
you